is YouTube too crowded is my niche too
crowded I don't have the resources I
don't have the money I don't have the
connections in order to succeed on
YouTube maybe you've heard these things
before maybe you've thought these things
before today we're going to be looking
at some of these comments thoughts and
what I would call myths about YouTube
we're gonna be busting them and
disproving six popular YouTube myths
that hold a lot of people back from
success and really talking about what
are the elements of success on YouTube
in 2020 and beyond but hey if you're
just joining the show my name is Sean
kennel and this is coffee with Cannell
I'm sipping on some Nespresso a little
Pete's coffee there and this is the show
where for the first 15 minutes we drop
some content some strategies so you can
get your mind right your grind on your
hustle fixed so you can grow your
influence leveraging online video
digital marketing and social media right
now and then in the second part I bring
you on the show so we can talk all about
what's happening in your life business
and answer your online video and YouTube
questions if we are just meeting I wrote
a book with my friend Benji called
YouTube secrets number one best-selling
YouTube strategy book run a couple
YouTube channels and am deeply
passionate about helping 10,000 purpose
driven people create a full-time living
doing what they love while making a
difference in the world with on-line
video so hit the like button if you're
fired up for today and man we gotta get
real with some myths and I don't know if
you've heard any of these let me know
what is the biggest excuse you tell
yourself about creating content on
YouTube or success on YouTube let me
know what is the biggest excuse that you
are telling your self is it that I don't
have enough time is it that I don't have
enough money is it that I don't have
enough connections is it that I don't
have enough what is what is the biggest
excuse if you'll be so bold and so
honest that
holds you back from success on YouTube
and your mind let me know and it's good
to see Lisa and Bridget and Tom here
we're gonna be looking at some YouTube
myths and what I've got a couple of
these and let me know if you've ever
heard some of these before
and so one is YouTube is too crowded
have you ever thought that before
YouTube is too crowded
that's have you thought about that like
as a too late there's so many people too
crowded that's a big one it's a big myth
that I've heard about about YouTube
let's see how about money I don't have
enough money to start YouTube I don't
have enough money to create content I
Drive enough money for a camera I asked
you some questions on Twitter if we're
not connected at Sean Cannell rhymes
with YouTube channel on Twitter
Instagram the community tab over on
think media and I asked you know what is
some of your biggest challenges right
now and some people said my gear like I
need a computer I don't have the right
equipment which would be like a money
thing right but so let me know what what
are some things that that are maybe
things that happen for you and let's
look at this though when it comes to
answers to those YouTube's too crowded
well did you know that half the world is
on social media right now yeah we just
looked this up right 3.8 billion people
use social media right now and that is
by the half of the year they said that
the world's total population would be
using social media by the middle of the
year Wow and so is YouTube crowded I'm
not saying it's not crowded is it too
crowded it's not too crowded it's not a
matter of how many people it's not just
how many people are creating how many
people are consuming and more people are
coming online all the time I read a
Huffington Post article they talked
about the coming surge as more people
get online as 5g as mobile phones as the
internet covers the earth that more more
people are coming online over 2 billion
monthly active users on YouTube so is
YouTube too crowded well yes there's
crowds but is it too crowded it's not
too crowded
people having success everyday you know
a good question is for all the aspiring
authors all the aspiring writers how
many books are published every year and
actually I was gonna look it up I didn't
look it up before how many books are
published each year and here's what's
crazy whoa a million there are somewhere
between 600,000 and 1 million books
published every year in the US alone now
does that mean it's difficult to stand
out and that in with your book of course
but does it mean it's impossible because
why every single year there's
best-selling books every single year
there is break out books so really as we
talk about these six myths the question
isn't really you know are they are they
like real like they sure you could say
them but they're more than really myths
or more kind of like excuses aren't they
okay let's talk about them so is YouTube
too crowded money well well money it's
not really a limitation or something
that can hold you back cuz you could
just use your smartphone and that's what
I asked this person I said well what
kind of phone you got there like an
iPhone 11 that's like what what kind of
limitation do you think you're letting I
understand maybe your smartphone's not
that good but they're like yeah I got it
I got an iPhone at 11 I was like that
thing will crush some video I don't know
if you've watched our smartphone video
series that Heather tours did with me on
think media but like we'll show you
step-by-step how to record on your phone
edit on your phone shoot a thumb thumb
nail on your phone upload from your cell
phone that's all you need
now again you literally might be you're
like Shawn I am locked in a dungeon with
no internet no phone no money and to
which point I would say how are you on
this coffee with candles stream right
now I mean that would be my next
question and so of course like there's
certain and not even to make light of
like deeply oppressive situations but
like if I I'm here to kill your excuses
today on coffee with can oh man I'm
bringing you a quad shot of excuse
murder pike let's let's just tear these
things apart you know Jim Rohn said
excuses are the nails used to build the
house of failure Oh Jim dog come on bro
excuses are the nails used to build the
house of failure I'm here to bust these
myths man these are just myths all right
how about talent talent talent can you
succeed on YouTube with absolutely no
talent of course not but like YouTube is
not Hollywood so you might say I just
don't feel like I have enough charisma I
don't feel like I have the right amount
of talent and to which I would say if
somebody else that looks like you sounds
like you is from your background is
around your ethnicity age has made it on
YouTube you can too do you need to grow
yours you might need to learn some skill
so you're gonna need to you might need
to intent you probably will but but do
you just uh I don't got the skills
learning I love the book title that
talent that Hustle beats talent when
talent doesn't hustle you know what I've
learned by about a lot of talented
people lazy man entitled talented
entitled because they rest on their
talent it's like The Tortoise and the
hare that that that hair if anybody
remember that story shot me on the
comments the hair was cocky the hair was
like dude I got I got the speed I got
the talent I'm good to go
and so it went to his head and the
tortoise in the meantime just hustled
one foot in front of the other never
gave up I'm here to kill your excuses
okay so we're talking about myths let me
know if you've ever thought any of these
and and really if you bring authenticity
and value you can overcome that lack of
talent of course get better but people
on YouTube connect with real like my
like Craig Groeschel says we want
leaders that are always real leap not
leaders that are always right I love
2020 to be honest you're like you love
2020 yeah because of social media
because social media promotes
authenticity
when people are really really you know
it works is more like you don't need
your videos to be over polished you need
them to be real authenticity and value
all right I don't got enough time this
is a legitimate one I mean I'm still
gonna destroy it but it's it's it's
legitimate a lot of you probably like
okay when can I find time to film
without the kids being loud when can I
find time to with school and with work
and with and so yes okay this is a
challenging one not enough time but the
question really becomes are you going to
make time like save the excuses it's not
about having time it's about making time
if it matters you will make time period
so maybe you got to think outside of the
box can you be like hey grandma can you
take the kids every Saturday hey mom can
you take the kids every Saturday and
that's the day that you shoot edit and
you do your thing like your dreams are
up to you you can either have make
excuses or get results I'm not saying
some be easy it's not gonna be easy it's
gonna be worth it to invest to build
your side hustle but people say there's
not enough time I look that's why I'm so
grateful that the chief operation
officer and what are the content
creators hosted to think marketing
podcast
Heather Torres as part of think media
team because she kills my excuses she's
juggling three kids running a team of 12
people at think media she's you know
taking care of her health she's taking
care of her spirit and a relationship
with God she's being a friend she's
doing she's doing the stuff how she
figured out she had to get disciplined
that's what she teaches all of us at
think media we're like Heather show us
your ways we're all learning calendar
blocking learning freaking time
management learning to take because we
go and this is like me this is how I
talk Oh Heather but I'll show and she's
like shot did you schedule it what gets
scheduled gets done are you gonna are
you gonna make excuses are you gonna get
results so where there's a will there's
a way like all I'm saying and look it's
not about your reso
it's about your resourcefulness okay so
I get time as scarce that is a limited
resource for you well then you better
start getting resourceful to figure out
how you're gonna get it done some of you
got money burning holes in your pocket
not a lot of you you're like who's that
person can I have some of their money
but some of you got money well why don't
you hire something you're trying to edit
your own videos why don't you hook up
with vid chops think media tools calm we
got a discount for you they'll help you
edit your videos not even that expensive
you really believe like you want to
treat this seriously where there's a
will there's a way it's not about your
resources it's about your
resourcefulness this is coffee with
kennel if I'm pushing your buttons then
please push the like button let me know
what you're drinking where you're
watching from we're gonna get to your
questions in just a second but we're
busting six myths I'm sipping on
espresso and I got a quad shot of excuse
devastation rolling through your town
right now I'm driving the excuse monster
truck crushing your little Kia Wow
Sean's fired up we got to kill these
things these zombies you're not helping
you okay only takes a few hours a week
well Shawn I have to like shoot I gotta
like shoot my video and it takes like 20
hours and then I have to edit it for
like 40 hours and then I have to like
worry and complain for another 20 hours
and then I call my best friend and I
complain to her for 40 hours well cool
you're you based on that current set up
you don't have enough hours but it maybe
if you stop complaining and started
working you could actually get some
videos done maybe if you simplified your
videos down a little bit I don't know I
got 48 strike
hopefully you jump on coffee you can tow
today well let's kill some excuses we'll
find a way let's make a plan let's find
a solution we can either find solutions
or we can study the problems I see
you're analyzing the problem studying
the problem looking about it from hey
mom I just kind of I'm here to talk
about my problems oh honey it's gonna be
okay dude you don't need your mom you
need coffee with Cannell to say stop the
excuses
love my mom but I'll tell you what my
mom's always there to listen to me whine
and complaint she goes you want a little
cheese with your wine cuz this is her
mom sir for man she brings the love and
the empathy I'm here to bring you the
tough love the hardcore love and you
need it because we got to get some
videos done because we got to build our
influence right now because we got to
protect our families build our future
I'll speed up there we go
connections I just don't have enough
connections only the people that succeed
on YouTube man they got shouted out they
got a collab oh if my brother was
pewdiepie if my sister was whoever you
know if I got the shout-out if I got the
connections if I grew up in Hollywood if
I grew up if I grew up in LA if I could
collab if I actually somebody was in my
city if there was a meetup near me if I
actually had stop the madness
it's all about the content not the
connections and look if you've got good
connections in a sick Network cool bruh
awesome but if you don't make content
anyways get on some zoom calls jump into
some Facebook groups or just put your
head down and press the record button
well I saw this channel and like they
just blew up and I've been working so
hard for three years but the Hat channel
like it just blew up in three months cuz
I got a shout-out from a connection well
that's probably why comparisons the
thief of joy and the thief of your
energy and the destroyer of your future
because if you constantly are studying
what everybody else is doing around you
and what every channel is doing around
you and all your energies going into all
the channels around you then it sounds
like you're not really working on your
own content but you're working and
worrying about everybody else
it's not about connections is about
content well this person over here has
all the connections I think got all the
time and they're a trust fund and they
got so much talent and they have
unlimited money and like they got
started in YouTube oh good I'm glad you
know every detail about everybody else
how's that
working out for you what if you took all
your energy all your creative energy all
your time spent complaining making
excuses and you invested that ends
creating and not complaining stop
consuming stop complaining
start creating I don't want to watch
coffee with kennel anymore Sean's me now
okay so funny he laughs at his own jokes
and this is so weird come on we got one
more for you someone took my ideas oh
that's so my idea new this is so funny
I had a URL once like a niche you are
well it wasn't like even a personal URL
it was it was a URL that i was just
using for like a webinar thing I was
doing idea to income dot tips and idea
to income dot live because someone took
the dot-com and my friend actually he
messaged me and he's like hey bro just
want you to know that like that's that's
like my my like my thing like idea to
income is like my thing he might see
this whatever you know I love you and I
was like dude what are you talking about
this is freaking 2020 like idea to
income is your thing you can't copyright
a book title you can't copyright a
youtube title I don't think you can
copyright a title like go get the
trademark I did I wasn't I didn't even
make a brand I bought a URL and had a
concept of a free training here's my
point but if you're worried about
someone else stealing your idea do you
know how many people have written like
the same book title dude you got to just
focus on building your thing mind your
business
I'm not saying plagiarize I'm just
saying I was like what the heck are you
talking about like that like idea to
income was your idea
like that's the most generic you know
how many people have a vision statement
helping you build your influence income
and impact which is like video
influencers tagline I hear that every
freaking day you go to one you go to an
entrepreneur conference every single
person's tagline look what's your
business doing or where does helping
people build their influence income and
impact imagine if I went up to those
people I was like comics
gives me sir yeah
those those were my three words Benji
and I started doing that five years ago
dude freaking Jim Rohn probably did it
five years before Tony Robbins probably
did it eight dude who get why you so
worried about what everybody else is
doing as if like the world is so small
dude you got a freaking build your thing
give me a break
someone took my ideas listen it proves
there's a market if you feel like
youtube's too crowded and someone's
already making the content you want to
make listen if they got 100 subscribers
500,000 subscribers and million
subscribers that's proof of concept
that's proof there's a market that's
proof that people want to consume that
content and guess what when someone
wants to watch YouTube strategy or
gaming content or Last of Us 2
walkthroughs or like more people want to
watch that stuff do you know how many
frickin playthroughs of cyberpunk SEPs
2077 there are right now there's
probably 200 and 400 500 channels all
getting 25,000 to 50,000 views off every
little thing and here you're sitting
here and like I didn't get an early copy
of the game somebody else got it now
listen you can either make excuses or
get results it's really your choice and
I hope that you're like no longer
watching this show good because I want
you to know that think media and think
marketing like look we're not gonna make
excuses in this community we're gonna
get results we're not gonna make excuses
we're gonna get results six myths
YouTube's too crowded it's not money I
don't have enough money you can find
money I don't got enough talent you can
get better and you can be authentic in
just that value I don't got enough time
you can find a way I don't got enough
connections you don't need them you just
got to create contact someone took my
ideas listen to proves there's a market
you gotta find a way it's not about your
resources it's about your
resourcefulness you know back in 2009 I
was starting a business called clear
vision media I'd have any money to start
a business
I got a little bit of money from a
project and I bought a Canon Vixia
camera but then I wanted to stand out
and be different and and really jump in
because the DSLR revolution started
and so the DSLR revolution right was
back when like the 5d mark ii came out
and then the 7d canon camera came out
and I wanted I was like oh dang I want
like that depth of field I want like
that fire you know background blurry
background type vibe and all that kind
of stuff and so I wanted to be able to
produce really sick you know depth of
field and all that kind of clear vision
media presents Benjy and Judy's wedding
right cuz this is a we grew up in the
same small town I made their wedding
video Benjy co-author of YouTube secrets
how do you learn video Sean self-taught
dog did you go to film school nah nah
saved a lot of money to buy not going
how do you get it done Doug so I wanted
to get a Canon 7d and I and I did so
what did I do I got a loan now I'm not
telling you to get to go in debt but
there's a way so I bought some
uzuki Joe like shoulder rig thing I got
a 7d Canon 7d I started watching videos
I bought a Philip Bloom tutorial DVD to
learn how to use the 7d before everybody
was given away dope free information
like we do on think media now dude I
just figure it away I remember I booked
a client and I didn't even know how to
use the camera yet so I freaked out so I
started to like learn study grow for
like two weeks straight bleeding my eyes
out to figure out how to get ready for a
particular shoot oh yeah those videos
aren't even on this is my clear vision
media channel I'm telling here it is I
got the the in preparation for this cuz
it was a good job I wanted to figure out
how to actually use the camera and like
set it up right and I didn't know how
and so you know I got like a light kid
and I was figuring out but all I'm
saying is I got alone I'm not telling
you to get alone I think you could
bootstrap
pick up a shift get a job make more tips
my job doesn't pay me enough get a
different job apply somewhere else
save your money stop buying dumb stuff
invest in your dream have I pushed your
buttons enough yet hey hit the like
button if you're getting value out of
today and let me know it which one of
these excuses you've had before and if
you've dealt with anyone here's a couple
final thoughts for you if you really
want to do it you do it there's no
excuses there's only two options you can
make progress or you can make excuses
listen excuses will always be there for
you but opportunity one won't there's
opportunity right now you can embrace
one of two choices either the pain of
discipline or the pain of regret pain of
discipline or you might have to stay up
a little bit later to edit your videos
after the kids go to sleep well Sean
easy for you to say you don't have kids
yet okay
well fine it's easy for me to say I'm
about to have one Sean Bradley can I'll
come in September 18th let's go my first
little son they said he was above
average when they did the ultrasound you
know how I'm saying come on
above average that means he's a big boy
good luck Sonya we'll be praying for you
come in September 18th man excuses will
always be there opportunity won't think
media think marketing we need to rewire
our brains our conversation imagine if
we just didn't talk in excuses we talked
in possibilities imagine if we didn't
see always the difficulties and the
problems we saw solutions imagine if we
started to change our perspective change
our energy change our emotions and
really lean in to say leadership is
about taking responsibility it's not
about making excuses it's about taking
responsibility owning this look nobody
is impressed with how good your excuses
are like wow those are some well
articulated excuses you have analyzed
that problem from every angle I'm so
impressed Wow
success occurs when your dreams get
bigger than your excuses come on hit the
like button if you got value hey today's
episode is brought to you by
the video ranking Academy we're gonna
get into some Q&A in just a second and
start busting excuses and looking for
solutions but those were six myths it's
been cool because we've been seeing so
much momentum in the Academy lately and
these are just some of the students
getting silver play buttons I wanted to
show you Mary and we actually have a
free class if you want to figure out how
to get ahead on YouTube you can you can
get a free class listen to the CS Lewis
quote you are never too old to set
another goal or dream a new dream come
on no excuses
keep dreaming keep setting goals and the
free class is at Tube influence calm I
will tell you there's a link in the
description or post that in the comments
but but Mary joined at the end of the
free class you'll hear about what's
called video ranking Academy and the
free class is like one free module out
of there that you'll get it to master
class so whether you want to join the
Academy or not no big deal but
definitely take the check take the free
class so Mary joined video ranking
Academy at 0 I'm pretty sure
Mary's nest traditional cooking for the
modern pioneer my god she's growing so
fast last time I checked she was at like
150 thousand subs she had two hundred
sixteen thousand now no big cheese
recipe and so you know I we hear it all
the time right like it's too late to
start she hasn't been on YouTube that
long I want to say it's like twelve
months or something she started like
within the last year two at max we can
look and and she's shooting in her
kitchen I'm just doing her content right
just breaking it down and she got her
silver play button making money figuring
things out and so I said what her oldest
video was here so oldest video was a
year ago my friends in the last 12
months Mary started posting content and
and talking to where she goes it was
kind of shawn talks kind of fast man he
dropped he's drinking a lot of coffee it
looks like but I just followed the steps
I just kept posting videos I learned the
best principles I'll in learning the
best practices two hundred sixteen
thousand subscribers and congratulations
of course to getting that silver play
button to
Mary and a lot of different people are
getting all kinds of different results
was cool is there's people assignment
about the silver play button I was
thinking about Tana Eliza in our
community she's only got only got 80,000
subscribers she made she doesn't go that
fast she may never get to a hundred
thousand she may never get a silver play
button she only makes a couple million a
year and only takes like eight weeks of
vacation a year so sometimes it's not
about your numbers it's about your niche
it's about what you're doing but if you
want to learn a little bit more about
that and get a free class that is part
of the video ranking academy you can
watch that at tube influence calm and
link in the description below if you're
watching this on think marketing and and
or drop that in the facebook comments as
well hit like if you get value out of
this video and share this with somebody
that you think maybe needs to destroy
their excuses a little bit we're gonna
bring on Kathy here Kathy welcome to
coffee Channel and Kathy where are you
from what is it you do on YouTube in
life business and and be honest with me
what is one excuse you've made before
when it comes to YouTube all right Sean
I am Kathy Walker I am in North Carolina
and actually I am it I used to be
assistant principal my podcast my
channel was year of a peeing dangerously
and yesterday I just got a job as a
principal so making a bit of a shift
career-wise limitations since the
lockdown I'm actually back at work but
technology was my excuse not that I'm
not tech savvy I'm wearing my little
lapel mic and I got light shining on me
but I I've had over thirty Amazon
deliveries cuz I just go I gotta have
that oh you know what I want that oh you
know what gimme gimme gimme
oh that looks neat oh you know what I
need a cannon and fifty oh no no I need
just tech overload and I I guess my
question though
is about making a change I just started
DRA I struggle with consuming more than
creating because I'm trying to take in
the courses trying to learn all I can
trying to play with my gadgets but you
know what my cam link just came
yesterday so I'm I'm all over the place
what is your YouTube gentlemen okay I
have two one is Kay walk comedy kwal KO
m e dy and basically it's just my
brother and i streaming weekly about pop
culture and then my professional one is
called year of AP AP ing dangerously
which is disciplined for aspiring and
current educational leaders that I
wanted to provide information in that
space and that's the one that I'm just
starting neither one of them has
followers so I'm just I'm a baby yeah
yeah yeah so okay great and this was
that was just me going live yes
chit-chatting okay a couple things that
I would encourage you to do I mean first
of all great job at starting I mean
great job of setting the channels up
getting some videos posting posted
starting messy five summaries for school
leaders don't say that you have no views
because that video has 26 views so
that's pretty cool even though at the
you're at the very very beginning
there's barely any videos to measure
right now but success does leave clues
and again one view twelve use eight
views one view five use twenty six views
so this kind of gives us a little bit of
some of a bright spot but even still I
just want to kind of call you back to
some of the basics when you first start
on YouTube you've got a take you could
write this down M is a some people teach
mi a but we teach mi si here at think
media and here's what it stands for it
stands for massive
imperfect strategic action taking
massive imperfect strategic action you
kind of feel all over the place good
that's what entrepreneurship feels like
you kind of feel like you're you got all
kinds of Amazon boxes coming good that's
what I did too I used ordering tech as a
way to procrastinate making videos back
in 2009 and 10 I kept saying you know
what I need a new lens before I put
myself out there cuz I'll be honest I
was I was strong at leaning into video
production in my for my business but I
was afraid to get on camera myself what
are people gonna think fear of other
people's opinions you got to keep taking
massive imperfect and messy and poop
your pants scared action but it should
be strategic and you have VRA to do that
so you want to follow the the system of
researching before you press record but
the one thing that I want to challenge
you in terms of now that you've started
your comedy channel and you're doing
live streams is I want to challenge you
to learn editing add even a basic level
I think that live streaming can be
something that we lean into that's
almost like I'm glad you're doing it
because it's showing your punching fear
in the face you're putting yourself out
there but when we start and everybody
watching really grab lean into this we
should be putting out short punchy
valuable thoughtful videos one of the
reasons why we oftentimes don't edit is
because it might take us seven hours to
edit the video 14 hour set of the video
but a reason a YouTube video often does
really well is because what you've done
is you've compressed time for the viewer
so you're actually serving the viewer
more why if you take an hour to explain
something that and there's no editing to
it the viewer doesn't get an efficient
experience but if you take if you record
for 45 minutes and edit that down into
seven minutes really that is in service
of the viewer to be brief be bright be
fun be done
so there's thoughtfulness of having to
structure your content having to edit
your content and so I just want to point
you to the new VRA foundations and your
members there
because one of the videos that we break
down is very early on is step by step
not knowing how to edit having to teach
yourself and learn and editing just on
her phone
hether invested in editing this video so
we break down about 22 different
strategies and little details in this
the video has 105 thousand views and is
still getting views now goes up it's
still ranked for home school versus
public school and this video again if if
she took 35 minutes to explain home
school versus public school it would
have saved her time but it wouldn't have
made it as good of an experience for the
viewer and it wouldn't have a hundred
and five thousand views today so the
next thing that I would recommend that
she do is yeah it'll maybe take more
time but put out a video that you're
proud of and doesn t like fancy editing
it's not like you know you need special
effects it's the jump cut it's the it's
the making it efficient it's the
answering the questions quick it's the
trimming the fluff so the more time you
spend you know making that content great
YouTube will reward you for that and the
last thing I'll say about that is I
heard a great communicator once I forget
who it was you know it's like maybe you
study communication books and whatnot
and might have been some great pastor or
somebody and they said if you are gonna
give me five minutes to talk I'm gonna
take five days to prepare if you give me
a half hour to talk I'm gonna take a
whole day to prepare if you give me an
hour to talk I don't need to prepare cuz
if I got an hour I can kind of just like
hey so here's a couple things I want you
got a time to just kind of waffle you
sort of take a rabbit trail and the head
talk they prepare for weeks because 17
minutes every word counts you really
want to dial in that content coffee with
kennel community think about especially
if a lot of your contents going longer
and longer and longer that doesn't
negate the live stream it does not
negate the practice of continuing to go
live and even the leveling up your
skills and your talent what I'm saying
is if you want to have some breakout
videos studying inside of your VR a
foundations that exact module why break
down and then think about how that could
apply to one of your videos because
that's the edge - we go well shoot if it
takes me 20 hours to get a video and
this is the thing Heather had kids or
has still does it and she was having to
edit a little bit each night couple
hours each night it took her multiple
days to edit this video to get it tight
I mean she you know she's making it
interesting she has a little black and
white zooms in a little bit teaching
herself to do it as she goes real basic
no lighting shot on her phone edited on
her phone but it was the intentionality
to the structure of the whole content
itself and it took her time up front
that video has 105 thousand views now
she grows her channel by on autopilot
because of rank videos by 300 or 500
subscribers a month because when you put
out good content cream always rises to
the top no matter how many cups of
coffee you pour that video I shot it and
I was stalled those limiting beliefs in
the editing because I did include a
couple of like a b-roll shots and I cut
to the different books and I wanted to
put up the little graphics so there was
almost a month of me kind of just you
know with this video where I was adding
little things to it and I'm seeing that
now okay and actually what's cool about
that is that it's proving my point
because it's by far your best viewed
video it's I think it's the most
interesting thumbnail you see our energy
in it you see the the text in it and
again it's I you're delivering that that
you're getting me the answer of what the
books are you're breaking of each down
you're popping it on screen so yeah then
I'd say get one percent better with
every upload but that was like my
biggest thing I felt in terms of talking
because even if we start out with a live
show and it's not that you can't grow a
live show but even without looking at
the comedy channel when someone doesn't
know you yet it's very hard to get them
to spend any significant amount of time
with you so if you give them quick value
three minute videos four minute videos 5
minute videos that are power they're
just
act and remember that YouTube is all
about this make a promise with your
title and deliver the promise in the
video let's imagine think you think what
the viewer the viewers like oh my gosh
you promise me something in the title
the opposite of that is click bait what
click bait is is promising something in
the title and not delivering it in the
video you feel cheated but you got you
to click and you're kind of mad about it
make just make a promise and so again if
if someone goes I promise that if you
pay me $10 I will give you a double
double burger animal style fries and a
diet coke and you go okay great and you
pay and you sit at your in-and-out table
for one hour two hours three hours
the reason I'm mad I'm eventually gonna
get it but the reason I'm mad is I
didn't get my double-double in a
reasonable amount of time
you're wasting my time and now I'm
getting angry I'm hungry and angry and
you're like my wife now get sprang gree
pregnant hungry and angry so I got to
keep her fed and so and you're making us
on the East Coast jealous because we
don't have in-and-out burger oh no ma'am
please
barely and so uh so that's so anyways
again if you promise it be brief be
bright be fun and be done deliver that
what burger place do you have on the
Iike east coast I we just have the
regular chains we don't have anything to
like the Sonic and you know Mickey bees
and stuff but not in and out burger I've
been out west and yeah it is what it is
we have you're on the East Coast Walker
we can tip button we can dip a Snickers
in in grease and fry it so that's that's
kind of our thing I like that we use the
deep fry Oreos when I worked at Rob in
the kitchen we'd had the deep fryer
through your deep fry and stuff back
there okay so so yeah I would say thanks
so much for coming I really appreciate
you and
hey Sean I don't behalf of I'm sure half
the people commenting we appreciate you
because you give such value and being
part of VRA I'm gonna keep working gonna
keep grinding all in but the value you
give to things like this and when you
guys go live I don't know whether people
let you know that that that is value and
we appreciate it and again one September
baby to a future daddy of a September
baby congratulations Kathy I appreciate
you so much thank you for coming on
coffee with Cannell and being a part of
our community thank you
all right take care coffee with kennel
is the show where we answer your
questions about social media YouTube
online video business gently press the
like button if you're again value out of
today we're killin excuses we're taking
action YouTube is as simple as making a
promise with your title and delivering
that promise in the video is that easy
not always easy is it worth it yeah
because a break out video remember
friends you're one video away from
changing your whole life and business
it's true loose there's thousands of
people that can testify that like a
video one of their videos have topped it
blew up and that was the tipping point
MIB video 34 you might be video 3 for
you it might be video 300 it's worth it
to put in the work get 1 percent better
with every upload and we're bringing
Kyle on today Kyle my man hey where are
you watching from I'm from st. Louis or
through those what is it you do and then
do you ever do you have any excuses
you've been fighting broke be honest
what is one of the biggest excuses about
YouTube that you tell yourself yeah so
I'm from st. Louis Missouri these are
fender stratocaster etc some of my
favorite things yeah I've got excuses
everybody's got excuses it would be my
biggest one hmm I keep telling myself I
got lack of time why is that on your
life you got like what's what fills your
time well you know I'm just trying to
keep up with work spend time with my
friends and family
do you sing bulimic what'd you say you
got single you got kids or anything no
I'm actually getting married pretty soon
here Oh Congrats exciting yeah
planning wedding then that takes time
yeah this yep so I'm trying to make
priorities I think that's probably the
answer to my question okay how much you
work around well I work 40 hours a week
for my job and then I usually try to put
in at least an hour on my website slash
my youtube channel awesome so tell me
about that what is it you do what's your
channel name it's called audio
University and so I went to school for
audio you audio production I have a job
doing that now but you know I've
realized there's a lot of stuff you can
learn in the job that you can get with
just real world experience but there's a
lot of like more in-depth information
that you can learn from school but you
know you don't necessarily have to pay
thousands of dollars to go to school I
can hopefully offer you that information
I'm just on my youtube channel man I
love that and you're teaching cool stuff
frequent frequency response
I like this crossover guide I actually
remember when I was getting into like
subs for my car see a man I'll pull the
picture out one of these days this is a
funny thing people don't know about
Heather Taurus and me when we were both
16 18 we were into like tricked-out
hot import nights Seattle fast and
furious we had Honda Civics
short shifters intakes we would
literally go to street races my car
wasn't that fast but I had the system
right and so I was getting the subs RMS
power with the amp you know and I
remember we'd be setting the crossover
so you clean that up and pull the you
know whatever frequencies out but I
don't even know half of what you know
and so that's really cool man how can I
help today like what's been going on
what's one of the question you have so
you know I like when a informational
video you know what is frequency
response how to place a mic on a guitar
'i'm i like when those are concise and
short and so i've been trying to do that
with my channel but i also I have a
belief that there's value in long-form
content as well
and I'd like to kind of introduce and
their channel of content was in my
channel I know a lot of people who know
people from school they know people in
the recording industry in the live sound
industry and with only having a thousand
channels I was wondering how could I
make it appealing to those people to
maybe get them on for an interview to
help give some real-world experience
that maybe I can't speak toward
firsthand but I can help translate to
the people who want to know that sort of
information you know do you want to
invite I mean there's people that I know
I have us you know a second connection
to that are like like what's that our
Dave rat an owner of he did live sound
for the Red Hot Chili Peppers you know
and so I'd love to get him on he
actually has a YouTube channel of his
own so it could probably probably be
some sort of collaboration and
opportunity but you know he's got
world-war fibers Dave Dave rat like the
animal r8e
got it yeah he's got way more
subscribers than me how do I make it
appealing for him to spend his time
doing that you know yeah that's a really
good question so I think that it's a
great a great vision I think people
would so you're talking about having an
interview show and you could just bring
him on and like zoom or something like
that right yeah see I think your and it
makes sense too because sometimes it's
like maybe the fear of reaching out and
whatnot but like dude your biggest video
has like 6k views and his keynote for
sound summit summit only has like 2000
so not to say that but like he's not I
guess he's not as out of reach maybe as
you would think and for him to come on
and do something like this with some
headphones I actually think in this
particular case he would be like
flattered and pumped and a lot of times
people that are successful RV plea
passionate about passing that a lot like
people reached out to us to do podcasts
and bring me on for interview for
YouTube tips or like even their school
projects and stuff I've done hundreds
probably like 150 200 of those
especially when it's a young person I'm
like for sure man like I wouldn't be who
I was if it wasn't for the mentors and
people that poured into me so I know
it's in one aspect I would go to Dave
at calm just right I'm a short but nice
email we're speaking gigs ok other
websites you know Dave right seminar
info because you're gonna click here to
request a seminar that's probably what I
would do
yes this particular case I'm I'm
connected with them on Facebook so maybe
that's the route there and then I could
just leverage my my network and ask
those people to ask yeah and I would say
a couple things to do is I've heard
people call this like the dream 50 of
their dream 100 step one make a list on
Google sheets or somewhere else of your
dream 50 or your dream 100 people you
want to have on this new show and I
think it's brilliant idea number two is
make columns of you know maybe their
Twitter their social media their email
make a box that says maybe you know Ryan
knows him like whatever so you can think
about following up number three create
your resources where you always want to
personalize the messaging you absolutely
do not want to just like spam everyone
and you wouldn't do that but you maybe
make a template of your key ask like hey
this is what I'm asking you to do here's
an example of one of my videos of course
lead with your strongest you know video
and say like yeah I'm teaching people
audio and here's an example in my video
it's got six thousand five hundred views
and they see that and then a couple
other things
think about your your branding and where
you're coming from on a professional
level including that email you know I
want you to know I hope that during that
call we can promote anything for you
because you always want to tune in to
the channel that everybody operates on
wifm what's in it for me and so when you
email that person it's you know whatever
it is but you go I I realized I just a
growing channel but I'd be happy to
promote your music or your seminars or
your whatever of course we could talk
about that start by asking maybe for a
shorter interview like there's no reason
it needs to be like an hour you might
just say it'd be awesome you know really
what it'd be cool to do about a
a 30-minute interview just jump on five
minutes before the audio check and you
made that might be emailed to so I make
I do two emails you know one has just
kind of that basic invite the second one
is like sure man what are the details
you just go okay hey and then eventually
hit up your dream 50 and hit everybody
up on the list and not like every day
but like hit everybody on the list and
then because you've organized it come
back to it a month later and see who
said yes a lot of people are gonna say
yes some if somebody doesn't reply don't
take it as a no take it as they didn't
see it because chances are they didn't
like sometimes people are like Shawn
I've you know how come you you've not
seen whatever I'm like well number one
when I check out from work I really
check out from work because I value
family so I'm not I can't constantly
answer comments in answering emails but
number two even with a team and help we
literally some stuff slips through the
cracks we get like thousands of messages
every day when you add up all the
platforms so a lot of times for people
that's not a no it's like try again I
just say I didn't see it and even if it
is a no even if the person did ignore it
sometimes the persistence of someone
wears me down and I'm like yeah man I
love the hustle I love the person I love
that you need to try this try once did
you been trying I see that you've been
kind of like active here's a tip be
active on his social media commenting on
his channel not as like a last minute
tactic but on your dream 150 that's why
you stay engaged in their communities if
they're launching a project and they do
a video where they say this is
especially true in my niche if it's an
author if I know they're launching a
book I had someone say no for a year and
then they were launching a book and then
guess what I asked if they'd come on
video influencers and guess what they
said yep because I said hey want to come
on and promote your new book and they
were like that's exactly that's the
season I'm in I'm now I'm doing radio
when you are studying the dream 50
you're paying attention to what they're
doing you'll get a lot of yeses and my
thought is you could fill a weekly show
up and it will the cool thing is that'll
take a little bit of hustle stuff you
could do on your break and stuff in
terms the email and follow up in
response but eventually your q will be
so full that you could have a weekly
show where
bring it on brain idea people like Dave
rat and and it becomes even like a
podcast or just kind of a video podcast
that's on YouTube and and then what
happens the kind of final thing and
there's maybe other nuances as well that
we would do because I guess I've had
interview shows now for almost 10 years
like over 10 years think International
was an interview show back in 2010 of
course video influencers and the final
thing is that it'll compound eventually
you're able to say here's some of our
past guests here some of the things that
have happened you can multiply some of
that content 30-minute interview with
Dave you know rat for five minutes he
talks about something very specific that
could have a very powerful title on
youtube so you chop that clip out and
that clip gets like 25,000 views you
start sharing that one to other people
and you're like yeah I've had Dave rad
from the you know red-hot whatever and
and you just compound it so really with
video influencers we kind of had two
things going for us one we had Benjy
knew some YouTube friends but one of our
first interviews was like Nikki
Phillippi and the reason I knew her it's
just it was like it was super organic
she you know she has 1.3 million
subscribers and and like two years
earlier it was just being active like
being true fans this five years ago was
one of our first ever video influencers
interviews 32,000 views like how'd you
know Nicky Phil about well two years
earlier she came to Vegas and did a
meet-up and Sonya and I went like hung
out met her so like it was like
literally two years later that I was
like hey we're starting like an
interview show and by the way to the
level of yeah like come over and shoot
it like what the heck and now I'm like
in a million subscriber youtubers house
it's all about kind of that consistency
that bizdev then by the way today I'm
like super close to chalene johnson i've
worked with her like now we've gone
snowboarding the reason she even said
yes to an interview Fitness celebrity
did it you know didn't know me same
thing well I was like yeah come over and
shoot in my gym I said what the heck are
you I tweeted her on Twitter she goes
well I saw that like whoever this
million subscriber Nikki Philip I person
like
let's chew in or a house so I figured
you weren't gonna kill me and and so
it's just like stacking that like video
after video relationship after
relationship adding value thinking about
what you can do to add value to what
they're doing and and being willing to
if like it's not a know if they don't
reply and when you got a dream 50 you'll
get your first five and then you'll get
another three and then eventually
someone will say yes and then eventually
your dream 50 becomes 150 people and you
start compounding in it becomes a
massive snowball yep it's just like
anything right you start small and then
one success opens doors to other
opportunities so that's great advice I
just got to start I never reached out to
him that's the that's the ticket you got
to start so no no doubt and I feel like
especially in that case I have a feeling
like he'll be like for sure man like I'd
be down to jump on Zoom and just you
know like be flattered what you know
he's probably like somewhat
independently wealthy and chilling and
making music you know I don't even know
and so literally like tomorrow like just
jump on Zoom from my house by the way
this is the era if I can speak to our
whole community this is a major era to
make connections like that because
people are so locked down people can't
travel their schedules were canceled and
so man don't sleep right now and I'm
talking to everybody in the think media
think marketing community like again
people my entire schedule this year got
cleared in terms of getting on planes
and speaking at events and we've
personally filled it up with like
challenge and hustling and wartime
leaders and like leaning in and a major
level but nevertheless like been on
podcast and been on stuff so if I can
encourage everybody this is a great
strategy that Kyle is talking about it's
a great way to add value build your
network there's so many powerful things
that come from this let me know in the
comments too if you've ever want to see
more training on unlike starting an
interview show I guess we probably at
this point I've interviewed 400 people
and done like 400 different YouTube
videos between our original project
think international and everything else
but don't waste this time because some
people that would they'll be busy in
2021 but in 2020 they could be a guest
on your show
so anyways man hey I appreciate you and
and thank you so much for coming on
coffee with kennel I appreciate it too
just like Kathy I have to let you know
that you know you've helped so many
people there have been times where I've
felt like everything was raining down on
me but this channel has let me know that
I'm not powerless you know I've got some
time before bedtime
early in the morning I've got technology
to work with then you know I can change
my situation so thank you you're welcome
Kyle I appreciate those kind words I
believe in you man literally what you're
doing in your channel in the momentum
you have it's looking really good just
keep building let's catch up in a year
when you're at fifty five thousand
subscribers all right will do
coins drop take care you too man coffee
with can Oh who here who's one person
you want to interview you don't even
actually have to do an interview show
just bring an interview on your on your
channel like it could just add value to
your audience by the way another word
for it is collab it's just a collab you
know back in the olden days when we left
our houses and went into public I
remember we were at a conference and
Heather did this collab with a
homeschool mom named Christie and just
kind of ran into her like hey I know who
you are like you also have a channel and
this video was shot by Mel on a
smartphone I don't think there was a
microphone in outside of like a hotel
and I know we can't go outside but it's
even better because we can jump on zoom'
we could jump on stream yard this is
stream yard y'all like this is not hard
to do this like this is a webcam this is
a USB mic you got an internet connection
throw a light up do in front of a window
and just like I just brought on Kyle and
Kathy you could bring people on and do
an interview show or bring a couple
people on stream Meredith yes lets you
do ten people on screen right now I
don't if that's a good idea so a lot of
voices how do you have a content way
conversation but yeah and if you want to
learn more about stream yard I think a
lot of these people are kind of our
partners and friends our affiliates and
so we have a resource called think media
tools calm and on there you can see
various discounts and and just like if
you're like hey what software do you use
what's the stuff that that you use this
is our tool guide video editing tools
that we use
I mentioned vid chops earlier you can
actually get 10% off on their already
great prices if you're sick of editing
and you just want like an editor to help
you and it's very affordable in terms of
editing especially for business owners
and just a lot of different resources
all that is that think media tools
dot-com I do have a meeting but I think
we can get one more in here and then we
will kick the tires and light the fires
how do I pronounce your name fer DOS
give me an unmute your microphone for me
yes fer DOS welcome to coffee with
kennel where are you screaming from and
what do you do I am and I'm an expert on
ecology nurse I work at you know West
Coast premier Cancer Research Hospital
voted number one in US News and World
Report I won't give the name but you
could look it up and you'll know which
was number one west coast I was a chair
of the nurse practice council there and
it's just kind of a scary time right now
in medicine and nursing and I'm sorry
I'm so nervous
I've been watching it learning from you
for months and months on end and I just
decided I was also owned a very
successful restaurant Indian restaurant
here in LA and I decided it was time to
kind of combine my research skills and
my medicine skills and combine them with
my restaurant skills and do a channels
so my channels called shake the kitchen
and the concept is were shaking things
up we're teaching people the research
and the medicine behind the ingredients
that we use how can it help you people
on chemotherapy they lose taste and
sensation how can you have high flavored
foods so that you can have that back
because they don't want to eat and then
they don't want
if they feel even sicker because food
doesn't taste like anything they might
eat you know Cheetos hot chips you know
but that's not nutritious so I'm trying
to combine you know all of those things
if your keto dieting people don't
understand you know the research behind
it and how can it help you as an
individual if you're doing intermittent
fasting which is new I've been doing it
for 30 years as a Muslim so there's a
lot of value in terms of my experience
and my education that I wanted to share
through my channel and being a Muslim
woman being in front of TV it's been
kind of a difficult process to get going
so even though I've been in the program
for about six months learning and
educating myself I've really only
started posting about three weeks ago
and my family's kind of catching on with
in a mile of my house I swear to you kid
you not I could have 300 subscribers
today if I shared this information but
it's a little hard you know like I said
it's a little hard being a woman and
being a Muslim woman because it's like
well why do you need to do that you're
you know you're an oncology nurse you're
this you're that but they don't realize
that the safety that I'm you know
jeopardizing being in that space and how
I'm maybe you know sharing that with my
family and I don't want to do that right
now you know I want to kind of be able
to maybe a year or two years from now if
it makes sense to be able to just move
into that business and maybe away from
medicine for a little bit of time
awesome well first of all thank you so
much for jumping on coffee Cannell thank
you for like your service and your
mission and your love for people to be
in medicine and prepared for you and
your friends too and just for everybody
like our frontline workers are
absolutely a blessing and hugely needed
and I can't even imagine the overwhelm
and of what's happening with this whole
COBIT season what is and I muted you
because of a little bit of background
noise but we can unmute here in a second
what is the exact channel is its shake
the kitchen yes okay great just just
having trouble finding it let's see
and you know if I'm doing anything wrong
shake the kitchen so I'm gonna look at
channels sha ke and and if the channel
is new that's exactly how it's done
have you done a channel URL yet I mean
you also maybe could send me I don't
know if you're on your phone the link in
the private Xtreme yard okay yeah try to
do that and then but let me know how can
I help work the question oh no probably
sending him the link though she could be
back hey coffee with kennel will give
Firdos a chance to jump back on here
what's an excuse you're busting this
week what's an excuse you're refusing to
let hold you back this week we talked
about six myths six limitations six
excuses and of course you know are we
saying that those are sometimes not even
legitimate no they can be real but let
me know in the comments what your
excuses are and which ones you're
choosing I'm not gonna make excuses I'm
gonna get results all right for dos
thank you for the link and work your
question so my question is that I don't
know if it's something I need to worry
about or when you look at my thumbnails
you know I kind of feel like having me
in them presenting my food would be nice
but I don't know I'm a little hesitant
on that and I'd love to hear your
thoughts on that
awesome well one of the first things I'm
going to say is I want the community to
kind of encourage you if if you will a
little bit as it pertains to
how they would feel because I think that
sometimes we can get in our own head so
you can watch the replay on any of the
Facebook pages or the live chat in think
marketing I think that there is just
something powerful about the YouTube
community about being you leading with
your beauty leading with your culture
leading with your values leading with
who you are remember it's the difference
my friend Rory Vaden said it brilliantly
on Instagram this week and this kind of
goes into our myths today it goes into
our challenge challenges and he said
this don't differentiate yourself based
on what you do differentiate yourself
based on who you are so if we're honest
this cooking channel is not what you do
is not radically different then there's
other people even doing that but who you
are not only on things like being Muslim
and and the dress and like those details
that's unique but even just you your you
are also unique I'm sure your humor your
personal like your incredible acumen as
a nurse your knowledge like what you
bring all of the medical knowledge are
bringing in and how that's going to help
people with anti-inflammatory properties
like you get us bring who you are and
that is that major major point of
difference so I want to encourage you to
amplify that I want to encourage you I I
don't think actually that you could
experiment with putting yourself in the
thumbnail but for that tip I want to say
success leaves clues and that in most
cases when it comes to food the best
performing food thumbnails are the
result the person's gonna get when
cooking see like lamb curry is giant
pictures of lamb curry you know if we
were to say asparagus or something a
Sperry ok I don't know how to spell
stuff s there I guess you know you're
gonna mostly have asparagus unless
you're going Ramsey and maybe you're
recognizable so it's like the actual so
you could experiment but
like success leaves clues other cooking
channels I think lead with with that
food
I don't even think you necessarily need
these words around the outside because
the words are in the title you can't see
those really small words so you already
have this like man I want to meet that
lamb curry like show me that full screen
now if this is the result the videos
gonna get me
I want these spicy deviled eggs keto you
have a lot of opportunity I mean you
ought to get a 182 views on your first
video two three weeks ago without
telling your 300 family members so I
think that should be encouraging - I
know you'd want to but that's like
that's that's absolutely insane it's
like your third video in and I'm
reminded of when I started I was not
getting 182 videos and so on
I hope that a lot of that just
encourages you to to jump in punch fear
in the face and and not overthink it and
the other thing I want that is
interesting which is amazing by the way
that you have 300 family members within
a mile of you is I remember when I was
first starting YouTube in Marysville
Washington small town hour north of
Seattle and actually whether it was
friends whether his family whether it's
people in my church I don't want to
insinuate that I didn't have like kind
of a tight-knit group that was
supportive around me like my friend Jeff
Moore's and a mentor in my life he was
very encouraging and actually nobody was
like discouraging actually in a major
way but nobody understood and they were
all mystified and there was a level of
like what are you doing I don't
understand it like why are you doing
that like I don't get it I would want to
sit down and have lunch with a friend
and I would kind of want to geek out
talking about YouTube or building
something or my dreams and like it was
almost like there was like glass over
the person's eyes and they'd be like
would you see the game though like do
see the game recently and and there was
like a disconnect between my dreams and
ambition and and let us know if you're
watching this on coffee with Calif you
sometimes feel alone or isolated or or
misunderstood or like those around you
don't see what you see or they don't
hold the vision and what I want to
encourage you with that is I kind of
actually want to encourage you
you almost when you add up these two
videos you got over 300 people that have
watched you videos right now you know
that are not your family members and
that's kind of what I learned I was like
wow I'm actually connecting online with
people who already understand like I'm
connecting online with people who do
care because YouTube will bring me to
what is the power to build that
community and then it shouldn't I don't
believe that should create division it
was sort of it was just that like I
started a venture at one point I went to
a few holiday gatherings or family
gatherings and I would sort of like try
and talk about what I did but eventually
I kind of became cool with it I was like
how's the game you know like I would
just was like this is kind of the vibe
here like that's great and I definitely
looked though to link arms and connect
just like this to stay connected like
communities like think media coffee with
Cannell or video ranking mechanic like
whatever I looked and I was like okay
let me like get that support that
information in books and podcasts and
then let me support and be around
friends and family and over time I'm 10
years in is it good I got a million
subscribers like I got a gold play but
now it it wasn't literally a couple
weeks ago when I was on CNBC for like
sort of the first time with a few people
they were like oh Sean like has like
kind of a real job like I guess if like
and it wasn't until like traditional
media which by the way you don't need
traditional media to validate new new
media is destroying or surpassing
traditional media but so I don't know
kind of went on a rant there but just to
kind of encourage you with I think I
know your ambition is so inspiring to me
because you're already an expert nurse
you're already doing it actually is kind
of a legitimate like confusing myth or
limitation like well you already got a
great job like why don't you just do
that like why would you do this - why
are you doing and and don't be surprised
you know that people don't understand
don't expect people to understand your
grind when God didn't give them your
vision like you got a vision for three
years from now you got a vision for side
income and you got a lot of opportunity
with the knowledge in your head
getting 1% better with every upload with
how you're gonna use food to heal people
and really help people especially
recovering from cancer and other things
it's really gonna be massive and again I
think everybody when you go back and
read the comments you're gonna see that
there's gonna be plenty of people that
are like no I want to see somebody I can
relate with or I can connect with or
somebody that is different or somebody
that's like me your vibe will attract
your tribe and don't misunderstand me
you'll get criticism and you'll get and
you probably I'm sure you already have
I'm sure you have already had to deal
with judgment or like people being rude
and and you know like at the hospital
like I'm sure you know what I mean like
people that are absolute jerks and
people that you know we just need to
pray for him right like they just
they're not loving and embracing of
others and they just everyone's got
opinions and so by putting yourself out
on YouTube I'm you might have saw the
faux paux fear of other people's
opinions that it doesn't mean of course
everyone's gonna be pumped but just as
much as some people be like you know why
are you wearing that on your head other
people would be like man her confidence
that's somebody wow her wisdom Wow her
beauty her knowledge and so that's kind
of what I would say let me know if
there's like any follow-up questions to
that or if that kind of is helpful in
terms of your channel it's hard you know
in this day and age sometimes kind of
separate yourself from that it's always
something at the back of your mind and
it's something the back of my mind all
the time and I always have to you know
think about it and be concerned about it
and and so when I started this channel
it was still there you know and I just
wasn't sure how I wanted to present
myself but I have so much value and so
much information that I want to share
you know award-winning recipes for my
restaurant and all the oncology research
experience from over 15 years it needs
to come out and people need to know so
they can feel better and and feel better
from the research not just you know
someone who doesn't have the the medical
experience someone who really has done
both the medical and the restaurant 100%
and that's I I believe in you whole I
mean when you can
your acumen and your experience and the
things you've done it's a matter of
bringing that on YouTube I want to
encourage you with one final thing um
[Applause]
don't stop creating now in light of this
tip but I want to challenge you to keep
leveling up your production value
meaning you know obviously you can
probably say that this is the camera's a
little shaky even that that's maybe a
tripod or something like the it's it's
it's a little bit hazy and here's the
deal like this video can do amazing so I
want you creating with exactly what you
have right now for as long as it takes
or as long as until the next move up and
I also believe that creativity does work
best in constraints we talked to Cathy
earlier and sometimes when we over get
into maybe upping our production value
it actually slows us down but summary
goal is just work on getting 1% better
with every upload like maybe I'd be
happy to see another 30 to 50 videos
that look kind of just like these like
hitting different topics and hitting
titles but be thinking about always
levelling up a little bit because that
is certainly one thing I note you know
as we start this video and they're kind
of like the framing and the haziness
kind of of the lighting and what not
even just pulling more better results
out of your that's that's a shot
composition thing right there you know
we're seeing all of this and all of this
and not very much of you and that's
we're here if we think media and think
marketing and all the training we're
here to help you know once we get into
this this actually starts looking very
good
very sharp the photography looks very
sharp the teaching looks very sharp but
yeah I hope that encourages small tweaks
lead to giant Peaks and so over time
that's true I think for every channel
but with you know just like at the
restaurant its presentation it's the
presentation of the food it's a
presentation not just the food itself
look impatient hey I appreciate you and
they keep so much for coming on coffee
with cannabis helpful today
absolutely it totally busted all the
myths for me and gave me so much
confidence because again you know being
a woman and being Muslim you know those
things are really difficult to go
against and my husband my kids everybody
is so supportive to me now and yes I
finally have the nice mic that you
suggest and the lighting and all of that
stuff so you'll be so proud of my next
video it's gonna look really good let's
go fer dos I appreciate you so much
grateful for you and thanks for coming
on talking with Channel thank you hey
y'all coffee with Ken all the weekly Q&A
show where we bring you on and answer
your questions about video social media
business and getting your mind right
your grind on we are killing excuses and
if you're just joining and you haven't
checked out the replay watch because at
the beginning we busted six different
myths related to YouTube today's episode
is brought to you by our free youtube
masterclass you can watch that at tube
influence calm link in the description
below we have a advanced group online
course and coaching program called video
ranking Academy but out of that session
if you want one free session from that
program go to tube influence comm you
could type tube influence calm into your
browser on safari on your phone or if
you're watching this on think marketing
YouTube channel link in the description
or will also drop that in the youtube
comments below and you can watch that
for free at the end of it you'll hear
more about that program and and get any
questions that you want answered about
that but listen if it's not right for
you it's all good like we just want you
to know that there's a next step you
could take to get focused strategic
YouTube training as well as group
coaching on it's really where we break
down our proprietary process where we
teach the seven hours of over exposing
pieces of paper oh there you go
there's 7vr ARS you can kind of see them
there and we go through this process and
go deep in all of these so start at tube
influence calm totally free and listen
stay subscribed stay engaged to think
marketing to think media channel
were there to help you get your lighting
right get your cameras right get your
settings right get you YouTube tips and
get your mind right if you haven't
listened to this month weeks thick
marketing podcast we're doing an episode
about money mindsets so we are in your
corner whatever stage in the journey
you're at I understand that we're in
tough times right now a lot of people
are whether it's unemployment or going
through hard times like you stay with
our community you know if you can't join
video break academy that's cool
like stay connected community and I
really believe that you're gonna see
we're gonna deliver so much value so
much strategy that you just know that
when the time is right we're here for
you we're there we're grinded Tony's
doing this tip of the day we got the VRA
show happening we got the Facebook
community all that stuff's happening but
in the meantime we're also doing this
show and all of our other shows to help
you go further faster building your
influence with video and with YouTube
hit the like button if you got value out
of today drop in the comments question
of the day what is one excuse you are
refusing to let stay in excuse I don't
have enough time now you just got to
make time I love what Kyle said he said
man it's probably priorities for me I
just gotta prioritize yeah gotta
prioritize someone took my ideas not
spoof there's a market I don't have
talent now I can level up I'm gonna take
it's about authenticity and value I
don't have money I can get alone I'm not
suggesting you get alone but that's what
I did that's how I got some stuff I went
to prosper com affiliate link I'm just
kidding
they probably have a sick of Philly they
do actually they have a sick affiliate
program it's like a little crowd funded
loan place and please I'm not suggesting
you take on debt I just knew that I
could work at Red Robin extra if my
video business didn't work out and I
could pay down the loan I got a seven
thousand dollar loan and bought gear and
a computer and all the gear I needed to
start a video production business what
is my point not that you should get a
loan to buy gear my point is that it's
not about your resources it's about your
resourcefulness while you're making
excuses somebody else is getting results
because they're finding a way where
there's a will there's a way
and I know the will your vision your
passion what you're fighting for what
you're building for the
opportunity that you see excuses will
always be there for you opportunity
won't choose discipline not regret and
check the replay if you want to see us
go little bit deeper on crushing excuses
love you thank you so much for being a
part of coffee with candle today I can't
wait till next week when we hang out
again and in the meantime keep crushing
it keep smashing it keep rocking it keep
blowing it up keep destroying okay like
the longest and okay I appreciate you
seeing the next one peace